as a case study into how the rise of
china is wrecking minds in the west i
give to you this week
plucky new zealand
the land of lord of the rings and seven
sheep to every person has found itself
caught in the gravity of the shifting
great powers
this is the accusation facing the kiwis
even some of your closest allies
have said that you're too weak on china
are they right has new zealand
been too soft on china in order to
protect trade
so here's the dilemma for new zealand
does it stick with the financial
lifeline offered by the giant that is
china
aka the bad guys or does it stick
with the familiarity and nefariousness
of his english-speaking powers
of the five eyes spying alliance i
aka the bad guys so before we go any
further a quick explanation of the five
eyes this is a global spying alliance
who share intel with each other
made up of the nations of the so-called
anglo-sphere that's the us uk canada
australia and new zealand i always
wondered why they call themselves the
five eyes instead of the ten eyes i mean
they're all missing an eye
anyway if you look closely at the
members you'll see it helps if you not
only speak english but
that you're generally speaking white
this is not a club for just any former
colony of the british empire and it only
has the best interests of everyone at
heart
so up until recently it was pretty much
a no-brainer for new zealand or should
we call it landing strip
5 to be a junior member of this
executive club
it made washington happy washington gave
it little tummy rubs in exchange for
stolen
intelligence signals and before the
anglo-sphericans had decided that
beijing was enemy number one happy days
only china started to get big
really big and china is now the main
target for the spies of the five eyes
and china
is new zealand's biggest trading partner
of all trade to be exact so you see the
dilemma
this is how new zealand's unmistakable
foreign minister
nanaya mahuta has attempted to explain
why the country has recently decided not
to join its spy pals
in condemning beijing that the
five eyes arrangement is about a
security and
intelligence framework and it's not
necessary
all the time on every issue to invoke
five eyes as your first port of call
in terms of creating a coalition of
support around particular issues in the
human rights space for example
ostensibly new zealand is saying that
the five eyes may have overstepped its
remit which is spying
not diplomatic although what it's
actually saying is that we ain't gonna
wreck our economy in the name of
so-called values
because what makes this such a great
example of the power of china's
influence
new zealand's prime minister is so nice
so perfect
it's nauseating this is a woman who
loves those human rights
however mother teresa jacinda and
you know her halo's slipped she's no
longer a state a saint that she portrays
herself to be
yeah jacinda adern champion of the
downtrodden he's taking fire because
she's staying pretty stunned
on the alleged abuse of the poor old
uyga muslims in china
here she is politically squirming when
asked about the five eyes versus china
issue on australia's abc news
shouldn't western nations be
collectively voicing their concerns
about countries like
china in fact i would totally
agree with what you've just said
collective country should
and we should be banding together where
we see issues globally that don't align
with the values that we share
to save us all time she replies to that
and a follow-up question
without even saying the word china which
is pretty impressive really
so you can see just how powerful those
bucks from beijing really are when it
comes to changing principles and
priorities
and that's why the other partners of the
five eyes are so angry at new zealand
for bending over so easily for china
but it's supposed to bend over easily
for them australia next door is going a
different route
it's actually criticizing beijing's
indiscretions cancelling trade
agreements
and even welcome back one of australia's
most powerful national security leaders
is sounding the alarm over a war with
china declaring
the drums of war are beating closer and
that kind of policy
has led to this for the best part of a
year
china's trade sanctions have hit
industry after industry
you can be sure new zealand wants none
of that treatment however much its
english-speaking spy buddies disapprove
and screw those principles too